foreign
[Music]
that's what you get staying out partying
all night I'm a promoter I'm working I
got like 18 000 followers you know who
got followers Jesus take your rude ass
to work you just curse what would Jesus
say Jesus would say shut the [ __ ] up
this is my house
see you later you need the cleanest
place I've got all day what the [ __ ]
accounts just loved itself who's playing
is this man Steve Jobs Steve Jobs is
dead fool I'm in his house died
dude got Miami [ __ ] Cleveland [ __ ] La
[ __ ] damn bigger city bro
oh my God we in LeBron's house LeBron
who James hey there go go you are one
handsome [ __ ] he got a hologram
of himself just to give him compliments
you handled the decision to go to Miami
perfectly nah that's a cat
I need 10 G's by next week I gotta pay
for my daughter's school they on
vacation how about we throw the party in
the King's house we gonna invite all the
celebrities we can make 10 times the
money we can send Destiny to preschool
College whatever tonight is our last
shot looks like we up I'll do it though
hi I see you there how are you oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm going to jail Kevin hi I'm
Peter is LeBron home
um by the way
black lives matter they do I posted two
squares on my Instagram respect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I wouldn't do something like this unless
I was desperate
she ain't cracking bro
[Music]
out of control this party is
[ __ ] we done [ __ ] up the koala
you good what the [ __ ] [ __ ] just
happened
your hairline is perfect anyone who says
otherwise it's just jealous this guy
[Music]